[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome to the Chubb
fellowship lecture with our
distinguished guest Bill McKibben
award-winning environmental activist and
writer the piece you just heard is
titled sunsinger composed and performed
by Grammy Award winner Paul winter and
accompanied by Janet yay who is pursuing
her master of Musical Arts degree at
Yale's
Institute of sacred music and School of
Music a pioneer of world music Paul
winter has won seven Grammy Awards for
his unique genre of Earth music which
interweaves the voices of the greater
Symphony of the wild with instrumental
voices from classical jazz and
indigenous traditions of the world
through the beauty of sound he aims to
introduce musical audiences to the
variety of species and ecosystems on
earth this music is often improvised and
recorded in natural acoustic spaces to
reflect the qualities and instincts
brought into play by the environment
with this music paul winter has found
the means to connect people to a sense
of place promote relatedness to the
larger community of life and assist
groups supporting local cultural and
biological diversity he has performed
hundreds of benefit concerts and used
his compositions to serve environmental
causes in a range of countries including
Russia Brazil Israel Japan and Spain so
today we are delighted that Paul winter
shaped his performance of sunsinger
to take advantage of Woolsey's beautiful
pipe organ built in the early 20th
century using 5000 pieces of pipes and
components recycled from earlier retired
organs seems quite fitting for today's
topic his music I hope has served to
gather and center us for this
afternoon's chubb lecture
I want to take a moment and thank our
sponsors for today's program along with
the Chubb fellowship we are supported by
the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies the Yale
sustainable Food Program and the forum
on religion and ecology before we begin
I ask that you turn off all your cell
phones so that you do not disrupt
today's program and by the way my name
is Mary Lou I'm a professor in the
Department of American Studies and
history and and I'm also the current
head of Timothy Dwight College as the
head of Timothy Dwight College I have
the honor of serving as the custodian of
the illustrious Chubb fellowship
established in 1941 out of a prior large
donation for education purposes made in
1936 by Hendon Chubb a graduate of the
Yale class of 1895 since its
establishment the Chubb fund has
appeared to the goals of providing
encouragement and aid to students
interested in government and American
public affairs the fellowship initially
aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and state affairs grew
over the years to include numerous
distinguished visitors and national and
international affairs as well as leaders
in the world of the arts and humanities
since the 1940s the Chubb fellows
lecture series has inspired generations
of Yale students to undertake public
service and pursue leadership roles in
the hopes of creating a better world
today and for posterity the fellowship
has hosted four US presidents George HW
Bush Gerald Ford Jimmy Carter and Harry
Truman in recent years we've welcomed a
wide range of national and international
leaders including Wendell Berry Samantha
power
dr. hawa Abdi Shah Rukh Khan and Paul
Simon with this quick description of the
history and aims of the Chubb fellowship
I'm delighted that we're welcoming today
Bill McKibben
I'm also delighted to welcome sue
Halpern she's right there
bill mckibben spouse who was herself a
renowned writer road Scholar Guggenheim
Award winner and Yale alum welcome sue
introducing milk bill mckibben will be
Mary evelyn tucker who is a senior
lecturer and research scholar at yale
with appointments in the school of
forestry and environmental studies as
well as the Divinity School and the
Department of Religious Studies she
teaches in the joint MA program in
religion and ecology and directs the
forum on religion and ecology at Yale
with her husband Jain Grimm she's been
involved with the earth charter since
its exception and served on the
International earth charter drafting
committee from 1997 to 2000 and was a
member of the Earth Charter
International Council please join me in
welcoming professor Mary Evelyn Tucker
to the podium
[Applause]
many thanks to Mary Lou Susan wiggler
Mary Kay Kaminski and the Timothy Dwight
students for all their work on the chub
Fellowship our special thanks also to
Paul winter on saxophone and Janet yay
on organ for that magnificent opening to
today's event I've known Paul for over
40 years and like vintage wine he is a
joy to drink in a national treasure for
all that he has contributed to the
environmental movement over so many
decades one more round of applause for
Paul
[Applause]
and this afternoon we will hear from
another national treasure bill mckibben
bill has won numerous awards including
the Gandhi Peace Prize presented here in
New Haven and the Right Livelihood award
in Sweden which is also known as an
alternative Nobel he is the recipient of
18 honorary degrees and is a fellow of
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences bill lives in Vermont with Sue
where he is Schumann distinguished
scholar in environmental studies at
Middlebury College but maybe his claim
to fame here at Yale is that he was
arrested in 2009 in front of the White
House with Gus Beth our former dean at
the School of Forestry and environmental
studies another Chubb fellow and noted
writer wendell berry demonstrated with
them for climate justice bill has
written 13 best-selling books that have
changed the conversation on many topics
including how to move beyond the
economic growth model and how to live
with less and reflections on hope I like
many others first encountered bill and
the pages of The New Yorker where he
went to become a staff writer after
graduating from Harvard at age 28
it was his 57 page essay in The New
Yorker that awoke so many of us to the
effects of global warming I still have
the issue which is eerily dated
September 11th 1989 the book was
published in that same year and was
titled the end of nature it has been
printed in more than 20 languages and
used by teachers across the country
including me
but if best-selling books weren't enough
bill has become a distinctive kind of
writer and activist let me try and
describe this special leadership role he
has moved into although often
reluctantly over the last decade
bill has created with the help of many
others especially gifted Middlebury
students a global climate change
movement that is no small feat three
fifty.org is the hub of the movement but
the spokes are numerous and they extend
widely across the country and around the
world 350.org has organized 20000
rallies in every country on the planet
except North Korea spearheaded the
resistance to the Keystone pipeline and
launched the fastest growing fossil fuel
divestment movement they have been
visible in making they have made visible
the heartbreaking plight of climate
refugees here and abroad
all of this would merit a Nobel as I
want bill over the years there are two
things that come to mind as to why he
has been so remarkably successful I
would say it comes down to strategy and
spirituality both are brimming with his
particular intelligence and authenticity
I offer these two observations to see
what we all might learn from bill to
continue to build an environmental
movement that is inclusive nimble and
creative attentive to the cry of the
earth and the cry of the poor as Pope
Francis's encyclical laudato si reminds
us in its clarion call for eco justice
bill's work and the encyclical should
encourage those of us that Yale faculty
and students and staff alike to speak
out regarding the greatest cutbacks and
environmental regulations and funding
for science research in our nation's
history to deny climate change and its
devastating effects around the planet at
the highest levels of our government
especially at the Environmental
Protection Agency is no longer Kalitta
li expedient it is morally bankrupt to
repeal
to repeal the clean power plan would be
ignoring the fact that we are already in
a worldwide revolution toward a clean
energy future keenly embraced by China
Germany and many in the business
community in the US as the carry
initiative conference demonstrated here
at Yale so what can we learn from Bill
about strategy and spirituality that we
can bring into our thinking and teaching
here at Yale bill is one of the most
strategic thinkers I know coming out
with creative campaign ideas and then
implementing them with amazing effect it
is partly because he works
intergenerationally drawing in students
and young people who want to know how to
get involved this includes our own
fossil fuel Yale which will have a
meeting after this talk in silliman
college please join them at an include
supporting Tim DeChristopher who will
speak at the forestry school on October
24th but the other reason bill has
become a leader is because he holds open
a space into which emerges a moral force
around climate justice and a spiritual
energy around nature there are few
people who can do this without preaching
but bill in his modest and unassuming
way has allowed that moral energy to
guide him and that spiritual force of
nature to renew him for the work ahead
in doing this he gives us all the sense
that against great odds hope will not
desert us we live in difficult times yet
the beauty of the earth will continue to
inspire us to create a flourishing
future please join me in welcoming Bill
McKibben
[Applause]
Wow
thank you
enormous ly its
very very very very good to be here
thanks to Mary Evelyn and to Mary Lou
and to everybody at Timothy Dwight and
at Yale for having me it was good fun to
arrive on campus and see all the posters
that were up and they had a big picture
of me in a t-shirt and across the top it
said in big letters simply too hot and I
must say that conforms with my
self-image completely and it's it's so
rare that people recognize it I did
worry when I saw it that you all would
think that I was just a pretty face
you know and that's why I made sure that
my wife came with me where Sue's here
someplace
there she is she's the actual beauty in
our family but also the the brain she
was a graduate of this institution of
Morris College and then she was the
first female Rhodes Scholar in the
country that's all of which is to say
all of which all of which is to say
since the the president was talking
about IQs today I just want you to know
that the the mean IQ of our household is
very high and if there are any problems
we have with me I want you to take them
up with sue afterwards okay um you've
heard a great deal about climate here in
in recent weeks and my guess is that
most of you are on board with the basic
proposition that climate change is a
deep problem and that we need to do
something about it and in that you are
like most people in this country and in
this world the polling data shows that
quite clearly Donald Trump
notwithstanding and more on him later
this intellectual argument about the
existence of climate change is is
largely one a consensus established
within the scientific community long ago
so today I want to try and advance the
discussion a little further beyond that
the question the word that I want to
highlight here today the focus of my
remarks will be the word pace okay how
fast are we going to deal with this
crisis and I'll try to do that in five
parts the first is to describe the pace
of this unfolding crisis to date I did
as Marilyn said write the first book
about this back in nineteen and eighty
nine which I am well aware was before
many of you were born at that time
we knew that we were in trouble we
understood that when you burned coal and
gas and oil you put carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere we knew that the
molecular structure of co2 trapped heat
that would otherwise radiate back out to
space what we did not know then was how
fast this was going to happen
and how hard it was going to pinch and
the story of the last 30 years is it's
happening much faster and pinching much
harder than people would have guessed
the most commonly used phrase by
scientists in papers over the last 10
years has probably been faster than
expected the things that we're seeing
now the phenomenon playing out around
the world were things that thirty years
ago we would have guessed would have
happened late in this century but as it
turned out the pace of climate changed
the the world was more finely balanced
than we understood so far we have raised
the temperature of our earth one degree
Celsius one point seven or so degrees
Fahrenheit that doesn't sound like an
enormous amount but in the context of
the planet it turns out to be quite
large we could express it in other units
if we wanted to and that might make it
easier each day the carbon that we've
put in the atmosphere traps the heat
equivalent of four hundred thousand
hiroshi amma sized bombs okay that's
enough heat to do enormous things and we
can see them now unfolding more than
half of the summer sea ice in the Arctic
is gone think about how much heat it
takes to melt a continent sized
millenias Auld meters thick sheet of ice
to turn it from white to blue the planet
looks from a satellite entirely
different than it did 40 years ago there
is a lot less white up top we're an
ocean planet 70% of our surface is the
sea and the sea we have forced to
undergo astonishing changes in the most
blink of an eye some of the carbon that
we've poured into the atmosphere is
absorbed in the seawater and as it is
absorbed it changes the chemistry of
that seawater the ocean is
roughly 30% more acidic than it was 40
years ago that combination of extra heat
and different chemistry in the ocean is
now wreaking violent damage su and I
were in the the Far Pacific 18 months or
so ago with our colleagues at 350 in the
Pacific who do amazing work trying to
protect those low-lying islands but we
happened to be there when the wave of
warm water in 2017 the warmest year ever
recorded on this planet when that wave
of warm water swept over the course of a
couple of weeks across the Pacific in
the indian oceans and as it did so it
wiped out 50 60 80 in some places a
hundred percent of the coral reefs
around those eight holes and Islands the
Great Barrier Reef is the largest living
structure on our planet but it is half
as living as it was 18 months ago
okay you can see the way that that heat
is expressed in the way that
hydrological cycles around the planet
have changed the way that water moves if
you wanted one fact to hold in your mind
to understand this century it would
probably be that warm water holds a warm
air holds more water vapor than cold
that means that in arid areas you get
far more evaporation and far more
droughts as you know we meet today while
our countrymen in California are cooking
with what looks like it may turn out to
be one of if not the biggest fire storms
that's ever hit that state that whole
cities that 36 hours ago were intact are
now in ashes that's the kind of thing we
see more and more of all over the planet
once that water has evaporated up into
the atmosphere it is going to come down
the average residence time for a
molecule of water vapor in the
atmosphere is only about seven days so
when it comes down now it comes down
hard
in deluge that we haven't seen before
the us set the new record for the
largest rainfall event in our history
last month when hurricane Harvey came
ashore in Texas some places saw 54
inches of rain four and a half feet of
rain think about that we can see it in
the way that when that storm has changed
the great cyclones and hurricanes of our
earth draw their power from the heat in
the first few meters of the Seas surface
when you raise the temperature of that
water you allow them to become more
powerful September the month just
concluded September of this year was the
most hurricane activity what the
scientists call accumulated cyclonic
energy that we've ever recorded in a
month in the Atlantic we saw what that
meant in Puerto Rico when our country
men and women there took the full brunt
in the eye of a category 5 hurricane
ripped diagonally across that country
and devastated everything in its path I
hope that I'm sure that most of you
already have I hope that people when
they go home will try to figure out
something material to do to help people
in the recovery from one of the greatest
catastrophes we've ever witnessed in
this country we see the effect simply in
the sheer heat that now envelops parts
of this planet a couple of times in the
last 18 months we've set the record for
the highest reliably recorded
temperature ever measured on this planet
in cities in Pakistan and in Iraq big
cities like Basra the temperature has
gotten above a hundred and twenty nine
degrees Fahrenheit
okay we're we're feeling warm today it's
80 degrees out think what it would feel
like to add 50 degrees to the
temperature we're feeling now people
can't work when it's a hundred and
twenty-nine degrees people can't sleep
when it's 129 degrees people really
can't live very long if it stays a
hundred and twenty-nine degrees because
your body simply can't cool off fast
enough when Paul Winter and Janet yeh
were playing and summoning up the beauty
of this world that we were born into it
is sobering to reflect on how much we
have already changed that planet how
discordant some of those notes are
already becoming on this earth this is
already the biggest thing that human
beings have ever done and the most
unjust because there's an almost perfect
inverse relationship between how much of
this trouble you caused and how quickly
and how hard it comes after you so
that's the first consideration about
pace so far we've done a lot of damage
the second consideration is what the
pace of damage is likely to be in the
years ahead
even if all the nations of the world
kept the promises that they made as part
of the Paris climate Accords and of
course our nation the largest
contributor over time to carbon in the
atmosphere has already announced it will
renege break go back on the promises it
made in Paris
something that should cause every
American a real pang of shame but even
if we kept those promises the actions
that countries have pledged are small
enough and slow enough that the
temperature of the earth would continue
to rise something like three and a half
degrees Celsius in
a lifetime of people in this room six or
seven degrees if indeed we allow that to
happen
then we cannot have civilizations like
the ones we are used to having that is
the bottom line those zones when it
becomes too hot for human beings really
to successfully inhabit places will
expand steadily out from the equator
until they cover a sizable portion of
the Earth's surface and as people
retreat above them and below them to
find some respite from the heat they'll
find a host of other problems some of
them extremely basic we believe at this
point that each degree increase in
global average temperature should cut
grain yields something like 10% so if
I've told you that it's going to raise
temperature three degrees you can do the
math in your head and figure out what
that's going to be like on a planet with
seven billion headed for nine billion
people and less and less in the way of
calories we're already seeing dramatic
rises in sea level okay enough so that
coastal cities are already threatened
there were pictures three days ago from
Miami where there was a so-called King
tied to the high tide of the year with
the full moon and water was in the
streets of Miami Beach just like it had
been when Hurricane Emma came through a
couple of weeks before but we've just
begun to see what's going on we've
understood now that we are near tipping
points in Greenland and in the West
Antarctic and that that continental ice
that's currently above rock is beginning
to melt in much the same way that the
sea ice has already melted when that sea
ice melted it did not raise the sea any
more than melting the ice and your drink
sends it over the top but when that ice
that's above rock melts it does indeed
raise the Seas surface
we thought as recently as two or three
years ago that we might get away with as
little as a meter three feet of
sea-level rise this century those
numbers now seem very optimistic indeed
and we're looking at two or maybe three
times that much and then extending far
on into the future because the last time
we let carbon dioxide get as high as it
currently is hundreds of thousands of
years ago the sea level settled many
many many meters higher than it is now
high enough to make sure that we can't
inhabit the coastal cities where so much
of our population now lives high enough
to make sure that much of the world's
richest farmland the river deltas and
Plains especially of Asia will be
underwater and unproductive we worry
that we're near very near the tipping
point because of that melt in Greenland
where the conveyor belt of ocean current
that brings warmth north from the
tropics will begin to slow or even
collapse an enormous effect and we're
worried in fact we're all but certain
that if we keep on this same path of
pouring ever more carbon into the
atmosphere that the oceans will go from
their current already perilously
acidified state into something much
darker than that the conference of
marine biologists meeting a year and a
half ago at the end of the conference
published their joint report they said
that on current trends we can expect an
ocean that by century's end is in their
words sour hot and choking okay all of
this means that we are at least in the
beginning stages of what is likely to
become the sixth great mass extinct
event on this planet we think that the
other extinction events even the most
recent have been driven at least in part
by the same thing we're seeing now the
release of massive quantities of carbon
dioxide into the atmosphere as natural
deposits of coal or gas or oil were
burned by volcanic activity now it is us
that is doing the burning and we're
doing it more quickly than we've ever
seen in the geologic record so that is
the pace of the immediate future this is
what happens if we keep doing what we're
doing now if we keep on the pace that we
congratulated ourselves at Paris for
getting on ok that's what happens which
brings me to the third section a nicer
one the possible pace of the future is
very different we have been given a
great gift in the last decade the
engineers have done their job and done
it very very well indeed the price of a
solar panel has fallen 80% in the last
decade around the world most places wind
energy is now the cheapest way that we
can produce electrons that means that
were because of that gift of the
engineers at the outer edge of possible
of changing those numbers vary
dramatically of moving far beyond what
people talked about in Paris mark
Jacobson and his team at Stanford have
produced plans for 139 nations around
the world and really all the ones with
significant carbon footprints showing
that by 2030 in all of them we could be
generating 80% of the power that we use
from the Sun from the wind and from
water from hydroelectricity it would
take an extraordinary amount of work to
do that but if we did we would be very
much on the path
to upsetting that math to getting way
ahead of the pace that we'd set for
ourselves and there are tantalizing
glimpses around the world of places that
are making it happen if you go to
Denmark you will find them generating
half their power from the wind either
the sly and crafty Danes have figured
out a way to steal the world's wind
supply for themselves or they have
figured out how to take advantage of the
same resources available to all of us
the resource they've added is the
political will to make it happen and
happen fast I had the extraordinary
pleasure of being in pretty remote rural
parts of Africa for a good portion of
the spring doing some reporting for The
New Yorker I was in Ghana and Cote
d'Ivoire and then across to East Africa
and Tanzania looking at villages that
have never had power and really in would
not have gotten it at best for several
lifetimes if they were waiting on the
grid to slowly expand there's still more
than a billion people on this planet
without power more people lack
electricity now then lacked electricity
the day that Thomas Edison invented the
light bulb okay almost all of them in
Africa or a lot in Asia but the bulk in
Africa um it was incredibly beautiful to
see those places come literally to light
for the first time because solar panels
had gotten cheap enough that the 30
cents a day that people were spending
for the kerosene to run one guttering
lamp that filled their house with smoke
would now leverage through the miracle
of small amounts of credit a solar panel
on the roof and an inverter on the wall
and four or five LED lights and a cell
phone charged
maybe a small television i sat one day
hot day much hotter than this in Ghana
with the elders of a village that had
just turned on this solar micro grid in
their village from the 40 or 50 small
houses their huts were now wired for the
first time and these elders of his
village were obviously very happy and
they kept giving me bottles of cold
water to drink which I was grateful for
cuz it was very hot it took me in my
clueless American Way a few minutes to
figure out why they were quite so proud
and happy to be giving me bottles of
cold water until two weeks before there
had never been anything cold in that
village okay that was the first time it
was it was beautiful to see that and
beautiful to reflect that it came from
the entirely benign process of pointing
a sheet of black glass at the sky and
letting the sun's beams be transmuted
into light and into cold and into all
the things that people need for a full
life that miracle is not one that we
should take for granted at all
this is JK Rowling's stuff you can point
a piece of glass at the sky and the
electrons come out the other end that
should allow us to change absolutely
everything but at the moment we're not
really making use of it we're not doing
it anywhere near fast enough to even
begin to catch up with physics yes by
the end of the century there will be
solar panels and windmills supplying
most of our energy free is a hard
business proposition to beat okay but at
the pace we are doing it those solar
panels and windmills will be powering a
busted world
our job is to make it go much faster
so the fourth reflection about pace is
why are we moving so slowly given that
we have the biggest crisis we've ever
faced as a planet and given that we have
a powerful solution at hand why are we
not putting it to use with the speed
with which we should and here I confess
is the part of the story that took me a
very long time too long I took myself to
think about how long it took me to
understand when I was 27 or 28 and wrote
the end of nature I believed that we
were engaged in an argument about
climate change and being a good writer
and academic I believed that the way one
proceeds in arguments is to write more
articles and hold more symposiums
perhaps some of the rest of you have
engaged in that work too and in most
cases it's exactly right but in this
case we'd won the argument the argument
had been settled by the middle of the
1990s the world's scientists had come
together and robust consensus about what
to do okay we'd won the argument but we
were losing the fight because it was not
about data and reason and so on it was a
fight as most fights are about money and
about power and the fossil fuel industry
the richest industry the world has ever
seen
had enough money and enough power to
despite having lost the argument
continue to win the fight
they were clearly willing to their hope
was is to extend their business model
another two or three decades and they
are willing to do it even at the cost of
breaking the one planet we have that
sounds hyperbolic and unkind
to say I might not have said it even a
few years ago it
that beginning about 2015 or so great
investigative reporters at the LA Times
in the Columbia Journalism school and
inside climate news and other places
began producing a series of the most
remarkable expose A's probably the most
important journalism anyone's done about
anything for a very long time what they
demonstrated beyond any doubt from
document troves from interviews with
whistleblowers was that the fossil fuel
industry its biggest players
particularly Exxon the single biggest
fossil fuel company nay the biggest
company on earth for much of the last 50
years had known everything that there
was to know about climate change and
known it by the late 1970s of the early
1980s they had all the money on earth
they had superb scientists their product
was carbon they set to work to find out
what was happening and they found out
their scientists told them how much it
was going to heat and how fast and they
were correct and their management
believed them Exxon started building all
its drilling rigs to compensate for the
sea-level rise that they knew was coming
they started mapping out the parts of
the Arctic they knew would soon be
melting so they could get the leases to
drill there okay what they didn't do was
tell any of the rest of us instead they
spent the next three decades spending
hundreds of millions of dollars to build
the architecture of deceit and denial
and disinformation that has kept us
locked in a completely phony debate over
the critical generation the generation
that may in many ways cost us much of
what we value on this planet there has
never been a corporate crime of that
magnitude had they merely said in 1989
when Jim Hansen was testifying before
Congress about the existence of global
warming had Exxon merely said you know
what our scientists found the same thing
no one would have accused them of being
climate alarmists
people would have said ok this is a
problem and we
best get to work on it we wouldn't have
solved it by now because it's a very big
problem but we would be well on the way
to solving it instead of moving rapidly
in the other direction
instead this lizard of disinformation
succeeded so well I think even beyond
their wildest dreams to the point where
we now have a President of the United
States who apparently believes sincerely
believes that climate change was a hoax
invented by the Chinese that is
incorrect
okay their plan their goal which we know
- from all these documents is not to
forever forestall this just to make the
conversion as slow as possible to raise
as much doubt to put as much mud in the
water as possible to keep us from acting
as swiftly as we need to act what do I
mean by mud in the water let me show you
a picture that's from a group called the
Heartland Institute originally set up
with money from Exxon funded by all
kinds of various fossil fuel groups that
devoted themselves to climate denial
over the years this was a set of
billboards that they set up around the
country and they took famous mass
murderers and put pictures of them next
to this they have one about Charles
Manson - I still believe in global
warming - you and that's Ted Kaczynski
the Unabomber a horrible figure in our
history one that Yael has had far too
much knowledge of you know the the the
legend the the billboard makes no sense
logical sense whatsoever I mean it's
like putting up a picture of Hitler and
saying I believe in gravity do you
you know but it's emotional meaning is
clear climate scientists are crazy
serial killers who are trying to wreck
your life okay that's the level at which
this campaign has been conceived and
carried out as it turned out the day
that those by surprise went up we at
350.org just happened to it that same
weekend with we do these huge global
days of action with rallies and things
around the world we had one set for that
time and we called it connect the dots
and it was for people in places all over
the world who had already felt the sting
of climate change to be rallying in
those places and so we were able we were
happy that same weekend to show what the
real face of climate change looked like
there were 3,000 of these rally the day
begins in the Far Pacific so there were
people down in the Marshalls on their
coral reef you know I'm talking about
its destruction you would think that
people in Afghanistan had worse things
to worry about but the Kabul River
drying up is a big deal all over the
world the pain of drought some places
the problems you know less
life-threatening but you know the
disappearance of the seasons for those
of us who psychologically mark our lives
by them as a big deal and one that that
hurts and should hurt those guys are in
the part of Siberia where we we now see
forest fires three four five degrees of
latitude north of where we've ever seen
them before and we see them routinely
last year Canada had to evacuate the
biggest city in the North Fort McMurray
hundred thousand people had to leave
their homes down a single road because
of wildfire that destroyed much of the
city people literally having to leave
their homes forever that's Micronesia
these people's houses are now wet they
can't live in them
anymore by the way as we're going
through me I could literally show you
these pictures all day and all night
because there's 75,000 of them in our
Flickr account and you're welcome to go
look at it
one of the things that's most compelling
about them and that struck me I don't
I'd spent my whole life hearing that
environmentalism was something that rich
white people did and if you didn't know
where your next meal was coming from you
wouldn't be an environmentalist it was
very early on into the process of this
work that we realized just from looking
at the pictures coming in from all over
the world and day after day of action
that almost everybody we were working
with was poor and black and brown and
Asian and young because that's what
almost the whole world is composed of
okay that's who the leaders of this
movement are it must be said that it has
crossed my mind once or twice that rich
white people might be slightly more the
problem than the solution okay to some
of our woes but we will leave that for
the moment the pictures were amazing if
it wasn't drought then it was flood
these people are in the part of Pakistan
that in 2010 saw the greatest flood
since Noah it rained so hard in the
Khyber Pass that by the time that water
had trickled down 25 percent of Pakistan
was under water 20 million people were
out of their homes and if you look at
them it does not take much imagination
to know that they are not the cause of
the problem that they are the victim of
okay what these people are demonstrating
is what our job is at this point and
this is the fifth and final section of
this talk our job is to speed up the
pace at which we make this transition to
act as accelerants in this process to
figure out each one of us in our lives
and
in our organizations how to build the
movements that push hard enough to make
this change happen fast enough to matter
I show you that picture because it's not
a big demonstration it might be the
smallest one that we ever had but it's
just six kids there are seven kids in a
street in Lake a and Haiti that turned
into a river and a storm I show it to
you for two reasons one is the sign that
those kids are holding your actions
affect me which is true we've seen what
happened to the Caribbean this last
month with Islands literally obliterated
there's nobody living on the island of
Barbuda anymore that people have been
there for hundreds of years but now
there is no one there because there is
no place to live your actions affect me
but not vice versa there's nothing that
anyone in Lake a can do to materially
affect the outcome of this problem they
can't burn less fossil fuel because they
don't burn any now they can't come to
the gates of the White House and try to
convince the world's sole super power to
do the honorable thing because we don't
let them into the country to come do
that kind of thing okay
they can't divest their holdings in
fossil fuel companies because I would
wager that the entire pool of investment
capital in the entire island of Haiti is
considerably smaller than the Yale
endowment all right um
it is our job now as institutions as
societies as communities to seize this
and work before it is too late the year
after that was taken Hurricane Matthew
swept through the Caribbean it did some
damage up in the Carolinas but the real
damage it did was in the southwest
Peninsula of Haiti 80% of the buildings
in Lake a were destroyed I have no idea
if those kids are still alive or not
because a lot of people died in the
course of that hurricane okay too late
for them that's why we have to pick up
the pace and especially now that we have
Donald Trump in Washington there is no
fallback argument for inaction no sense
that someone else is somehow going to
take care of it there are a number of
ways in which we can do that work of
picking up the pace we run we help
organize this whole big effort to as we
say keep it in the ground to keep fossil
fuel where it is by blocking every
proposed plan for a pipeline or a coal
port or a new fracking well or whatever
coal mine whatever it is and those
fights which really began with the
battle over the Keystone pipeline in
2011 a battle not yet settled but which
for seven years we've managed to keep
800,000 barrels a day of the dirtiest
oil underground thank you to all who
took part in that that battle has now
spread people saw that one could stand
up to the fossil fuel industry and so
now every one of those projects is met
with resistance and often it works we've
blocked all kinds of pipelines
TransCanada announced last week that it
was pulling the plug on its plans for an
even bigger pipeline out of the tar
sands to the
antek in Canada just last week Scotland
became the I think 14th country in the
world to ban fracking we had a huge day
of action three days ago in Australia
with 45 huge demonstrations against
plans for what would be the biggest coal
mine on planet earth I am all but
certain that we're going to be able to
beat it because the rise of popular
protests is so strong so keep it in the
ground we if there are those things
happening and you can figure out how to
join in that work then you should we
have massive campaigns going on across
the environmental movement now many many
groups lead really by the Sierra Club to
get cities and towns and counties and
states here and around the world to
commit to a hundred percent renewable
energy and that is beginning to work in
a big way at first of course it was
Berkeley and Madison Wisconsin that
signed up you know but now it's Atlanta
and it's San Diego and it is Salt Lake
City when Trump pulled us out of the
Paris climate Accord he said I was
elected to govern Pittsburgh not Paris
the next day the mayor of Pittsburgh
said thank you very much we've decided
to go a hundred percent renewable in our
city
so keep it in the ground and this fight
for renewable energy to provide the
stimulus the subsidy the pace to make
sure that it happens fast and one of the
other fights is to try and interfere
with the financing of the fossil fuel
industry that's why this divestment
fight has been so important around the
world it went much better than we ever
thought it would when we launched it
five years ago now I guess and at this
point there are endowments and
portfolios with assets of about six
trillion dollars that have divested from
fossil fuel earlier this week forty big
Catholic institutions chose Saint
Francis's feast day to divest their
holdings and they included the Diocese
of Assisi which was a beautiful moment
in this struggle the hardest places to
convince have been the rich elite
universities on the East Coast the
United States alright my alma mater
Harvard I think you I'm not sure it will
ever divest its ties to Wall Street are
so strong although there are people here
who are trying hard to make it happen we
will not stop I instead of my reunion
last time I got to spend the night in a
sleeping bag in the shrubbery outside
the president's office as part of a big
sit in around the thing and it was much
better than the reunion I must say it's
not okay at this date for places like
Yale to have hundreds of millions of
dollars invested in this stuff it's not
okay if it is wrong to wreck the planet
if it is
if it is wrong direct the planet than it
is wrong to profit from that wreckage
the profit from that wreckage is very
small any institutions that took the
advice of students five years ago and
divested have made out like bandits
because the fossil fuel sector has
underperformed every other part of but
it also means the other reason not to be
engaged in that work is remember that
picture I showed you about the Unabomber
if you're in bed with those companies
then you are engaged in the process of
undermining our democracy of spreading
lies constantly you're saying and doing
things that would get you kicked out of
Yale for violating the honor code if you
did them on a test or a paper okay it's
not any different if you do them with
the money that you invest and now
especially that we have Donald Trump in
office and so many people are saying how
sad they are about that now especially
is the time for people to understand
that we need to act at every other level
that we can act at because nothing is
going to happen in Washington at least
for the next few years so be good idea
to go have dinner in silliman annex with
all the good people from fossil-free
Yale or organizing hard and thanks to
them for keeping up this fight going
forward and
and they are by no means alone there is
resistance underway every place around
the world now as I say and it's
beautiful to watch and it comes from
everywhere so much leadership provided
by frontline communities and especially
I think most gratifying over the last
five years by this rapid emergence to
the leadership of indigenous traditions
around the world you saw what happened
at Standing Rock last autumn a beautiful
beautiful powerful gathering um it
didn't surprise me because the people
who organized that we've been working
with for years they are great leaders
it's a good sign that the oldest I was
saying this to someone at lunch that the
oldest wisdom tradition on the planet
the indigenous wisdom tradition is
meshing now powerfully with the newest
that the word that comes from the sweat
lodge and the word that comes from the
supercomputer is the same word about
what we need to be going okay
and now people gather in their numbers
you know these were 400,000 people on
the march in New York City a couple of
years ago until the woman's March at the
beginning of January the the biggest
marches about anything in this country
in a very long time and it wasn't just
in this country it was as usual all over
the entire world
I want to I think I want to close just
showing you a couple of pictures that
illustrate in my mind the kind of drama
of this moment in which we find
ourselves ok
you know there are sort of tropes that
go on and once that fit the human mind
our image of and one of them is the
Battle of the the small against the very
large ok the David and Goliath story
these are our friends in the Pacific in
those islands like Vanuatu and Tuvalu
and the marshals and Micronesia and the
Solomons that'll probably be underwater
by the end of the century but boy people
their slogan is we are not drowning we
are fighting and boy they are well we
were in marching in New York they'd cut
down on each Island a single tree and
made a big traditional war canoe and
they took them to Newcastle in the
Pacific which is the biggest coal port
in the world and there they used them
for a day to blockade that port and keep
the largest or ships in the world in
harbour so they couldn't come out
without running them over it was brave
and beautiful action it's been one of
the reasons that's things that's
galvanized Australians into opposing
this crazy plan for this giant coal mine
and it Illustrated perfectly this trope
that the small and the many against the
few and the very big we saw the same
image from the Pacific Northwest the
next year this was when shall all
announced that they were going to go
drill for oil in the Arctic okay think
about that for one minute by the way
okay
scientists had said if you warm the
planet the Arctic will melt shale oil
and its ilk paid no attention and went
ahead and what do you know the Arctic
melted having looked at that did the
leadership of shale oil say huh maybe we
should go into the solar business
instead this seems not to be working out
no the leadership of Shell Oil said hey
it's melted up there now it will be
easier to drill for more oil if you were
looking for an illustration to support
the argument that the big brain was not
a good adaptation okay that would be it
it seems to me on the scale of human
folly it doesn't get much larger but
happily there were lots of people with
perfectly good brains and big hearts
attached to them who decided to get in
the way and in Seattle and in Portland
for days they blockaded the two giant
drilling rigs with small craft we called
them chi activists okay and it was
beautiful and it it it threatened brand
damage to shell that was more than they
could contend with and by the end of the
year shell said well we didn't find
enough oil in the Arctic we're going
home really what they found was far more
trouble than they could deal with and so
they turned tail and ran and that was a
very good moment
but we need lots more moments like that
this I guess the way to say this is the
planet is now way way outside its
comfort zone that's what it means when
the Arctic is melting
when coral is dying because it is way
way outside its comfort zone we need to
be outside our comfort zones too we need
to be doing much more than we are doing
now because it is manifest that what we
are doing now is insufficient that's why
the temperature keeps going up ok now
what exactly it means to be outside your
comfort zone will be different for
different people but since we were over
at the forestry school earlier today I
was reminded I told the students there a
story about one of my great friends and
heroes Gus Speth who was the Dean of
that institution for a long time and
built that magnificent building there
and so on Gus Speth was one of the great
environmentalist is one of the great
environmentalists that this nation has
ever seen he helped found the Natural
Resources Defense Council and won many
of the lawsuits that helped us on begin
the process of environmental regulation
he was the first head of the President's
Council on Environmental Quality so he
quality so he worked the system from
Washington from the inside he went to
the UN where he ran the United Nations
Development Program the whole thing so
he worked the global bureaucracy from
the inside then he came and became a
Dean at Yale at which there is no higher
possible accomplishment
and then when he retired he wrote a book
looking back on his life and it was a
kind of sad book in a way because what
he said was none of the kind of inside
and obvious normal things that I did
very very well better than anybody else
added up to enough they didn't begin to
make the kind of change that we need to
make when I was recruiting people to
come to Washington for the civil
disobedience action that launched the
Keystone fight which became the largest
civil disobedience action in thirty
years in this country about anything
that sent twelve hundred and some people
to jail one of the first people that I
called was Gus spent and said will you
sign this letter with me and will you
come to Washington and he said yes I
will thank you very much he and I were
arrested on the first day of that
protest and because the police were
trying to send a message to the others
that were coming behind they treated us
somewhat more harshly than usually
people who are charged with failure to
yield are treated we spent three days in
Central cellblock in DC which is as much
fun as it sounds like it would be okay
um Gus was on the next cell over so we
could speak through the bars and we
talked a lot in fact he for the 50 or 60
people who were there he gave a lecture
through the cell bars about his new book
and it was excellent but he because his
son was a white-shoe lawyer who was
papering the jailhouse with writs he was
the only one of us who got out even for
a couple of minutes they let him go meet
his son shackled but he got to go talk
to his son briefly and he passed him a
message to pass to the reporters and
what he said was and I think that this
bears thinking about four elites of all
kinds which anybody who is at this
institution
is what he said the only sentence he
said was I've occupied a lot of
important positions in this city and
none of them seem as important as the
one I'm in right now okay that I think
bears thinking about as we decide what
we're gonna do you don't all have to go
get arrested although an increasing
number of people have explained to me
that it's now on their bucket list okay
and I will add looking at the great age
diversity in this audience when I wrote
the letter asking people to come to get
arrested there I said I don't think
young people should have to be the
cannon fodder in this case they're doing
most of the leading in this movement as
you've seen from the pictures but if
you're 20 - it's possible an arrest
record might not be the best item for
your resume okay one of the few unmixed
blessings of growing older is past a
certain point what the hell are they
going to do to you you know and and so
it was with pleasure that we saw people
with hair lines like mine descend on
Washington we did not say how old are
you that would be rude but we did
cleverly I think say who was president
when you were born okay and the two
biggest cohorts were from the FDR and
the Truman administration's on the last
day a man was arrested with a placard
around his neck that said World War two
veteran handle with care' he was so old
he had been born in the Warren Harding
administration which was so long ago I'd
forgotten there was a Warren Harding
administration it was good for the young
people who were there to see their
elders acting in the way that really
elders need to in a working civilization
I will just add that this same principle
of risk since we're at a university goes
triple for anyone with tenure okay
you guys are the most bulletproof people
in any place on earth put it to good use
we also told people if they wanted to
get arrested that they should wear a
necktie or a dress not because we're big
into formal wear sue and I live in
Vermont which I believe has a
constitutional provision exempting
people from wearing neckties okay we
wanted to make the same visual point
that I've been trying to make throughout
this talk there is nothing radical about
what we are talking about all we are
asking for is a world a little bit like
the one that we were born on to a little
bit of ice at the top and the bottom the
odd coral reef in the middle that's not
a radical demand that is a conservative
demand radicals work at all companies if
you get up in the morning willing to
make your fortune by altering the
chemical composition of the atmosphere
and you are willing to do it after
scientists have told you what will
happen and if you're willing to keep
doing it after you've seen it happening
then you are a radical in a way we have
not had on this planet before and our
job is to check that radicalism and it
is our job
and it is our job to check it fast
because that's the only way that matters
climate change is the first time limited
challenge humans have ever really had to
face okay dr. King would always end his
talks by saying the arc of the moral
universe is long but it bends toward
justice this may take a while but we're
gonna win the arc of the physical
universe is short and it bends toward
heat if we do not win soon then we will
not win ever
and that is why pace has become the most
important word why fast is the only
thing that really matters if you
remember no other line from this talk
remember this when it comes to climate
change
winning slowly is a different way of
losing okay because that's what we're
doing now we are winning very very
slowly and that is just another way of
losing I cannot guarantee you that we
will win this fight even if we do
everything right we have waited a long
time to get started it is a bad sign
that the world's ice sheets are rapidly
disintegrating that the chemistry of
seawater is changing I cannot guarantee
you that we do not know though the best
science indicates there is still a
narrow window narrow enclosing that we
should be able still perhaps to prop
open the only thing I can guarantee you
is that there is going to be a real
fight and you've seen it in all these
pictures from all over the world I am so
grateful to those who have been engaged
in this fight for a long time and I am
so grateful to all the reinforcements
that I know are coming from so many
other quarters it will be a great
privilege to get to stand
shoulder-to-shoulder with y'all thank
you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all
now I talked on for a very long time for
which I apologize
no moral opprobrium will attach to
anyone who decides that it would be
nicer to go out into this beautiful
evening but if there are students in
particular I think with some questions
or comments or abuse it would be okay to
offer it up where is the microphone Mary
over here something over there so if you
and and Mary's have you wanted students
in first to be asking questions all
right fire away if you've got a knee
this one working I got so to say thank
you so much for hurting us into action
today and I've got a question so you
talked about the hundreds of millions of
dollars that Yale has invested in fossil
fuel companies and we're really worried
about that as students we're also
wondering how can we imagine the role of
universities beyond divestment in terms
of responding to the climate crisis so
there's so many things that universities
need to be doing and of course Yale is
doing some of them magnificently the
work that goes on here the research and
teaching around these things is
extraordinarily important and the
modeling of different futures I had the
best lunch out at the Yale farm and
garden and it was very good to see we
need though people at Yale like people
everywhere else to beyond their role as
students and teachers and whatever else
to also assume the role of citizens
which is a role that we've sort of put
down too often
in recent years we need to take it up
again that means joining these larger
movements in the larger world outside
this bubble that are working on
pipelines and coal mines that are
working on pushing for a hundred percent
renewable energy you need to join up
with people you know there's lots of
things that one can do as an individual
and one should do our house and Vermont
is covered with solar panels and so on
and so forth but we try not to fool
ourselves that that's making much
difference the most important thing
individuals can do at this point is not
be individuals it is joined together
with other people in movements large
enough to matter that's why we set up
things like three fifty.org
hi thank you so much for coming this is
it a bit inarticulate question but I
guess like I feel like I'm lucky enough
here to be able studying environmental
things but I have a lot of friends who
have other day jobs and kind of
recognize that something small like buy
an electric car isn't enough but also
can't become full-time environmentalists
or activists and I was wondering if you
could speak more to the middle ground
we don't need most people to be
full-time environmentalists the work of
citizenship is done after hours and on
weekends okay that's when we need people
engaged there are enough people who are
doing this full-time either as
volunteers whatever to help coordinate
we don't even need 50% of Americans
engaged the academic literature is clear
that if you can get four or five percent
of any population actively engaged in a
fight it's almost always enough to carry
the day and we're starting to get close
Trump notwithstanding the polling data
is obvious we just now need to move so
fast that we need people stepping up so
bring them along in whatever stage you
can get them as engaged as it's possible
to get them
you say it may all repeat it
now since leaving the mines I've gone on
to work on just energy transition work
environmental activism attended college
in communications where I recently
graduated and throughout my work and
travels one of the problems I've seen in
the jobs versus the job sources
Environment Academy
is the perceived a citrus city or a
centricity of the environmental movement
amongst the majority of people
especially working-class conservatives
and it's so much so that the industry
has you in political advocates have used
that to exacerbate people's belief in
the rural urban divide they've used it
to exacerbate people's belief in
downward looking elitism from academia
so my question is how is 350.org and
other such organizations and academic
institutions working to address
working-class conservatives to
communicate across those lines to to
drive better socio-political change and
prevent another Trump from entering
office that's a really good question
I've spent much of our life living in
very red rural parts of the country and
so I know exactly where of you speak
most of our work at 350 isn't about that
our works trying to take the 70% of
people who are already engaged in you
already understand that there is a big
problem and get them active enough to
make a difference because most of them
aren't okay and that's mostly our
mission field you know but one works in
all kinds of other ways too so I'm a
I'm a Methodist and done a lot of work
over the years on building a religious
environmental movement among all kinds
of churches I was down a year ago at New
Orleans Baptist which is seminary which
is the I think the second biggest
Seminary in the Southern Baptist
Convention it was down there for a few
days and there was some of that
hostility at first you know Yankee in
the first place and Baptists don't
necessarily is and whatever else but
what really got people what really made
it a wonderful time was telling those
stories about what was happening with
renewable energy all over the place
one of the most interesting things is to
look at the polling data for solar
panels they're the only thing when you
ask people what's your opinion of solar
power and should the government be doing
more to support it you get eighty
percent of Republicans eighty percent of
Democrats and eighty percent of
independents say yes it's sometimes for
different reasons
you know conservatives tend to think I'd
really like this thing up here because I
don't want to depend on anybody else you
know and liberals tend to think god I
love the Sun it's really cool you know
and I don't know what independence thing
you know I don't know what their but
that's one of the ways in now I'm really
glad you're doing this work around just
transition because there has to be some
what I mean it's it's not the fault my
mother's family is all from West
Virginia from coal country it's not the
fault of people who mined coal that we
can't burn coal anymore okay and you
know the Trump's of the world have done
a good job of kind of holding them
hostage and using that but that
shouldn't be how it works and that's why
the work you're doing there is so
important we'll see how it comes out
the good news of course in the long run
is the cornucopia of jobs available as
we make this transition dwarfs the
amount of people who ever hardrock mined
in their life you know it's going to
take a lot of people swinging hammers up
on a hundred million American roofs to
carry out this solar revolution and it
is the best kind of work because no one
is going to put their house on a boat
and send it to China to get a solar
panel up on it it's work that stays here
so let's hope that we can figure out how
to bridge what are I think devised more
of culture than of interest in a sense
thank you
do we have time for one more dear man I
feel bad that we're keeping people going
but I'm happy to do let's do one more
here and then y'all can go out into the
nice night thanks for being here
my question for you is given everything
that you've told us about the science
given the political climate given that
Paris wasn't enough and we're not even
in it anymore what gives you hope well
you saw a bunch of those pictures and I
only showed you a tiny fraction even of
the ones I have on my computer you
should be grateful my there are now
millions of people around the world
engaged in this fight most of them are
in places that did not cause this
problem if they're willing to do that if
they're willing to work together with
the people who did cause this problem
then it seems like we have some
obligation to do it so even on days when
I'm not feeling all that hopeful that's
one of the things that keeps me going
but I think I'm remain against a certain
amount of evidence sometimes hopeful
that there really is something special
about enough about us as a species that
we will take the hint and not do
ourselves in
you know I mean it's such a remarkable
proposition that we stand on the edge of
the most perilous danger but we've
gotten the warning people have told us
that it's going to happen they've told
and there was no guarantee of that you
know if it turned out that the danger
point had been at 315 parts per million
not 350 then we would have passed it
long before we had the supercomputers
and the satellites in order to provide
that warning and I guess I want enough
and and hope enough that there's
something special about our species that
we will actually and it just it just
annoys the hell out of me when we don't
you know and and so that's one of the
things that that keeps me going thank
you for the work you're doing thank
everybody here for the work they're
doing on we go Thanks
you